A few months ago,
I did parkour up in Scotland,
and I made the mistake of
just absent-mindedly saying...
...that, "Oh, I wanna try
tightrope now!"
This is Chris!
Hello!
The Bullzini Family Circus Yard?
Circus Yard, that's where you are,
and tightrope is my thing.
So you've definitely come to the right place
if you wanna try tightrope.
Is "tightrope" the right word?
'Cause I've heard "highwire" and all sorts...
You can call it what you like.
It's a tensioned steel wire rope,
which is high.
So the reason why we call it "highwire",
as opposed to "tightwire",
or "dance wire" they
sometimes call a lower wire,
is because of the height obviously.
So it's a slightly different
mental and physical training.
So how are you with heights, Tom?
I— I'm fine with heights!
Falling, not so much.
It's not the falling.
It's not even the falling.
It's more of the landing
that can be dangerous.
Yeah, yeah, you're fine(!)
The first twenty metres will be great(!)
Exactly, just enjoy it.
Just the bit at the end...
The plan is not to drop you
on the ground. That's my job.
So don't worry. You're in safe hands.
But there is definitely a lot about
the mental process of preparing yourself.
So that's what I wanna do with you, is to get you
feeling really calm and really grounded.
Having a healthy respect
for heights and an awareness
that you don't want your body
to fall off and hit the ground.
For me, that's sane.
That's not being wimpy or foolish.
That's actually really sensible
and really sane.
And that's why
the technique, the training,
and the safety harness in this case
are really essential.
To, you know...
We're not as crazy as we look!
I don't know what to expect here.
I don't know the height of what we're...
Oh, that is— That— (laughs)
That's the height basically.
I saw Penn and Teller once.
Ah yeah.
And they were doing—
Something that stuck in my head
was the phrase that the trick is the same,
whether the rope is
one foot off the ground...
Yeah.
...or...
...gonna guess about
30 feet off the ground?
Yeah, it's actually a little bit less.
So it's already less than...
Okay! Okay!
...than you're worried about.
Eight metres.
Eight metres, okay.
It's "serious injury" territory
if you come off, though, isn't it?
Well it won't be for you, 'cause you'll be connected.
Obviously not, but...
It would be for me,
because I work without a safety harness.
But yeah, it's really not about
the F word.
And in fact, your training starts there.
Don't mention the F word.
Okay.
It's really not about that—
What we always have to do is
step onto the wire,
and be present on the wire,
with the confidence
that we're in control,
and we choose when
we're gonna get off the wire.
So really visualising that, really
establishing that in your mind's eye...
that's where it starts,
is believing that you can do it.
Normally at this point, I would have kind of
some sarcastic or self-deprecating—
But I'm not, I'm gonna buy into this,
'cause I'm gonna be up there soon!
Cool.
Absolutely.
I'm not gonna mention the F word.
I'm gonna walk across there.
Great, great, great, great.
Well, that's the place to start from.
Yeah, I believe you can do it,
so you know, that's at least one of us.
♪ (tense ticking music)
How do you do that? How on earth
do you balance like that?
(heavy sigh, clapping)
(music fades)
So, we're not going to
start you up there.
We're gonna start you
on something much safer and lower
just down here.
So if you wanna come this way,
I'm just gonna put the final tension on
to make sure that it's about right.
Just do that on this little device,
and that should be good like that.
Oh! (laughs)
So here's your balance pole.
That's... That's good.
That's got— That's got—
It's wide. There's a lot of balance
available here is what I'm thinking.
It's very long.
It is actually a shorter one.
Come and have a feel
of the pole on the ground.
'Kay.
Then I shall talk us through
some of the technique
before we get you onto the wire.
Okay.
It's— It's heavier than
I thought it was gonna be.
Yeah, that's what people
always say.
This one is about eight to ten kilos.
...Alright!
So how you hold it,
if you bring your hands a little bit wider,
bring the flat of your palms,
so your fingers are not even gripped around it.
That's it. That's better.
And then bring it up
so that the middle of it is,
yeah, around your belly, good.
Now pull your elbows in
towards your body,
and dropping your shoulders
down the back.
Okay, now that is much better.
Oh, okay!
A little bit wider in the hands.
A little bit wider.
Okay, cool.
So what I want is that
your fingers don't have to hold on.
It feels more like I've got a thing
just resting in each palm.
Yeah, to start with, yes.
If you need to wrap
the fingers around, you can.
Put it down if you
need to rest your arms for a bit.
Yeah, I think I'll save the...
save the muscles.
Again, just pat the arms out,
massage out,
'cause you'll be getting
a lot of tension doing this.
It's heavier than I thought it was gonna be.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So let me show you.
I'll show you first of all without the pole.
Okay.
And if you want to just watch,
and you can almost imagine yourself,
if you like, you can
imagine yourself being me.
And just be aware that
when the feet get on,
the correct foot position is for
the big toe to be over the wire,
and then through
the middle of the heel at the back.
And when you stand up onto the wire,
you'll have the pole,
but I'm just gonna balance
with my hands.
And then, my teacher in Cuba
used to say like this, it goes,
dedo, deslizar, talón, paso.
Dedo, deslizar, talón, paso.
So that's touch, forward—
Toe, slide,
heel, step.
That's right.
Toe, slide, heel, step.
Yeah.
So what we're doing with the eyes,
we're looking at a fixed point.
And the best fixed point to look at
is the point at the end of the wire,
because... that's where
we want to arrive.
Let's start with the feet.
Yep.
And I can help you with the pole.
Alright, so...
So...
If you hold that, and if
you remember the centre...
Open palm.
On the belly just there,
tucked in.
I'm going to support this,
so we don't have to worry too much
about balancing to start with.
Okay.
'Cause we wanna get those feet good.
If you need to fall off...
Yeah?
I'll just show you this
if you stand there for a second.
There are two ways
to leave the wire,
if you really have to leave the wire.
One way, which is not advisable,
is like that.
Yes! I have made that mistake
once in my life
on a slackline in a park,
and it hurt!
Yes!
Yup.
You only need to do that once
to realise that that's the way not to do it.
So being really aware that
if you do need to leave the wire,
then to go one side
or the other.
Magic. When you're ready,
come up with the other foot.
Stand up tall and straight.
Bring the pole up to your belly.
Good. Keep looking
at the end of the wire.
Both feet on the wire.
Oh, that's got a wobble on!
I've got a wobble. Nope, back down.
Breathe, breathe. OK, OK, OK.
Wow! That— That moves...
That moves a lot. Okay.
If you're really wobbly,
the wire will wobble.
So if you can use your breath
to calm your body...
(breathes deeply)
That's it. Super cool.
Super cool.
Toe on the wire.
When you're ready, allez-hup.
Great.
And other foot on the wire.
Good.
Okay, breathe. Pull the pole to your belly.
(titters)
Yep, pull up a bit.
Elbows into the body.
Cool, and when you're ready,
step forward.
And try to slide—
Wheeey!
Okay, you got it, you got it.
Stand up straight. Stand strong.
Hang on, no. I lost that.
Okay, okay, okay.
(laughs) Okay.
(laughs)
If you need to lean onto the pole...
Yeah.
So this is the next step.
We're gonna try a bit
of this now.
So when you get up
onto the wire with the pole,
And if you feel like
you need to fall off,
you just rest the pole down.
Oh, I can just rest the pole down!
Yep. And just rest the pole down.
Okay!
I can't do that up there!
No, no. But then you're getting
more comfortable
with where your feet are
on the wire.
Remember: toe, slide...
(hisses)
Pull the pole into the belly. Good.
Toe— Okay, keep breathing.
(groans shakily)
Yeah, no— (pants)
Keep breathing. You got it.
Cool. Toe. Good.
So make sure your foot
is really on the wire.
Really touch, gently test
that the wire is there
before you commit
to the footstep.
Yeah.
Okay, when you're ready.
I'm trying to work out
where the vibration's coming from.
It's just from your body.
(softly) Okay.
So relax your body.
Use the outbreath to relax.
(hisses, groans)
Okay, okay.
Check, where's the wire
in front of you?
The wire's moving too much!
I can't check where the wire is,
because the answer is
it's doing that!
The way that you're lightly touching
with the front foot as you slide,
so that's dampening,
it's like dampening a guitar string.
You know, if you touch onto it lightly,
you'll stop it vibrating.
Wow!
Really stay focused,
right til the very last.
Okay, cool!
Alright, well done.
Thank you for the assist on that.
I guess we just do that
a lot of times now.
♪ (lo-fi music)
(jitters)
Okay.
Lost it.
Lost it, lost it, lost it.
Halfway!
I need to put the pole down.
I need to physically put the pole down.
Yeah.
(groans)
(sigh) I'm keeping my feet
in a claw position.
It's painful. I need to let that relax.
Yeah.
Step by step.
(pained sigh)
Okay, cool!
(music ends)
I nearly hit you with the pole there.
Don't you worry.
I've had poles in the face before now.
Comes with the territory.
Well done, man.
That was really good.
That was the best one yet.
I touched down a few times over there, but...
The problem's in the soles.
That hurts now!
Yeah.
They're just not used to having...
...a thin metal wire...
cutting into them.
Yeah, I can only imagine.
That's painful!
(strained) It's putting all the pressure
on the same bit, every step...!
(roars angrily)
Oh, okay.
No. (growls)
It's that pressure, over and over
and over and over and over.
I might propose...
...that we have a look
at getting you high.
And see how we go from there.
You're at a place where you're
picking up the pole on your own,
you're balancing it
all the way across to the middle,
and then yeah, you're being restricted
by the pain in your feet.
It's a process.
(deep breath)
Yeah, surrender to the process.
'Kay.
See what it's like from the top then?
Yeah. Yeah.
Alright.
Great. That's really cool.
Lovely.
And yeah, step into that space,
and you'll see...
that there's not a lot to stand on.
There's not, but it's...
If this was wobbling,
I'd have a problem.
If I didn't have the wire on,
I'm okay with this. This is fine.
Cool, cool, cool.
That, on the other hand!
That's a lot longer than
I thought it was gonna be!
Before you look out there too much,
take a look around,
and get a view of Somerset...
that most people don't ever get to see.
Ahh. Yeah!
I'm gonna just go out
a little bit more here.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, the height is not bothering me.
Cool. Yeah.
That's fine.
Great.
This wire bounces up and down
more than that one does.
Yeah, it's a little bit longer wire,
so there is more elasticity in it.
This is good! If I can do—
If I can cross that wire,
I think I can cross this wire.
I'm sure you can!
I just can't cross that wire right now!
For my own peace of mind
when I'm up here...
could I try descending on this cable?
I'm happy with that.
Alright, so all I need to do is—
Yeah, the problem is
just putting my faith in this.
Yeah.
Sitting down.
Hooh, that's...
Alright, you got me?
(titters) And then just trust
there's some elasticity here.
He's got me!
He does indeed!
Yeah, you got me.
Thank you very much!
(wheezes)
This is...
This is undignified.
I'm gonna be honest with you.
I think it looks better
with flailing, Tom.
It does. It really does.
Move the feet and arms!
Yeah, just sitting there like
a sack of wet potatoes didn't help!
Thank you very much, Josh.
(sharp inhale) Alright.
Okay. Super.
(groans)
(long grunt)
Agh, no. No-no-no-no.
Ow-ow-ow-ow-ow-ow-ow-ow.
Okay, okay, okay.
No. (sharp breath)
Foot pain?
Foot pain.
Work on those footsteps.
No. That had to go down.
Okay, okay, okay.
Stay present, stay present.
Stand tall and straight. Easy.
Two more steps.
Clear steps.
Okay. Easy.
Super.
(slow breath)
That's it. So really working
with your relationship
to your body, your feet,
in this moment.
And keeping that pole strong...
(loud exhale)
...but loose.
(breathing intensifies)
Good, feeling the pole.
And sliding those feet.
Keeping forward,
keeping moving forward.
Good. You can step on
the cavalletti, no problem.
Good, 'cause I was going to.
Cool, cool.
Come on! Come on!
Keep going. Keep fighting.
Look at the end. Keep going forward.
Come on! Come on!
Stay strong in the belly.
Come on!
Keep stepping, step by step.
(grunts)
This is... really...
Yeah.
I wanna hear it. Breathing.
Keep breathing
all the way through.
You got six steps to go.
Keep going.
Slowly! Slowly at the end.
Wait all the way
until you're right there.
And then step.
Yes!
(breathing heavily)
(applauding)
Alright, you did it! Cool!
(grunts)
Have yourself a little break.
I have no idea
why that suddenly worked.
I have absolutely no idea.
That hurt like hell at the end!
And I have no idea why my brain
suddenly went, "You've got this."
You have got it.
That first two, three steps,
something went click,
and I guarantee you,
if I do that again right now,
I'll be off straight away.
Don't say that! Don't even think that.
Don't even think that.
Something about that was just:
"I've got this. This is the pattern.
It's locked in."
I'm going to make
a rubber-band racecar.
This is a crate from KiwiCo,
who make hands-on, fun, educational
projects for kids of all ages.
So if you've got kids, and you'd like to
keep them occupied and interested
without just shoving an iPad in front of them,
this may be for you.
They've sent me this, which is a
Tinker Crate, for ages nine and up.
And as there aren't any kids around here,
I'm gonna make it myself.
Every month, KiwiCo
will send out a new crate
with hands-on projects about science,
engineering, art, geography, or cooking,
or whatever your kids'
particular interests are.
Oh, that's clever! Okay.
There are nine different types of crate,
like the Koala Crate for preschoolers,
or the Doodle Crate for kids 9–13
with an interest in art and design.
or the Maker Crate
for fourteen and up.
"Yours may not look as even.
That's okay."
Alright.
All the crates have been put together
by expert designers and engineers,
and tested by kids.
And all the instructions, tools,
and materials you need are included.
They really did think of
everything here. That's really nice.
You can go to kiwico.com/tomscott
or click the link in the description
to get 50% off your first month
of any crate.
I would've genuinely enjoyed
that as a kid.
Genuinely enjoyed that now.
♪ (dramatic soaring music)
So how are you feeling
after yesterday?
Do you feel like
you're ready for today?
My thighs hurt.
Weirdly, out of all the bits.
(music ends)
My feet were fine this morning.
Great. That's good.
I rolled them out.
I tried to—
They're doing okay.
Thighs hurt, arms hurt a bit,
but I think I'll be okay.
Okay.
I just...
I just wanna make sure
I get over this one a few times
before... getting up there.
First one of day two.
Yeah.
I woke up so confident.
Let's see if you've forgotten it or...
I woke up with completely
unjustified confidence.
I woke up going,
"I'm fine. This is gonna be great."
I don't know.
I would say you earned your confidence.
I would say you worked
harder than I've seen
anyone who does
this work yesterday, so yeah.
Breathing, breathing, yeah.
We're not there yet.
Come on, Tom. Come on.
Get your eye in.
You had this yesterday.
Cool. Let it touch. It's great.
Keep the body straight
as you do so.
Let the arms bend down,
but keep the body straight.
Easy. Easy.
Great.
That was the best one
I've seen you do.
I would normally be trying to
almost distract myself,
try and let my unconscious, subconscious,
whatever it is, do the balancing for me.
But I have to keep my head in the game,
focusing on what I'm doing.
As soon as I start talking, as soon as I start
focusing on what's going on outside...
Well, I won't use the word, but yeah.
I see it as enforced meditation.
Yeah.
How much of that foot pain
yesterday was me being scared?
I don't know.
Oh, 100 percent.
I'm not saying 100 percent. That was...
(laughs)
I think a better question is,
how much are we capable of,
if we let go of all the fear?
Let's do it again. Let's do it again.
(laughs) Cool.
Enforced meditation
is absolutely the right term.
(snickers)
Any time I feel my brain going,
"Nope, not thinking about that."
Every time, my brain, I'll have to
bring it back, refocus on that.
It's definitely true.
All you've got to do
is what you do here...
...up there.
Great. Well, have a rest.
Let's do it.
Give yourself a bit of a
sit-down, rest your feet.
We'll get the pole up,
and we'll get the harness ready for you.
Alright.
Amazing. Well done, Tom.
Let's do it.
Thank you, thank you.
♪ (hollow tense music)
I can tell you that
that first step
is the most difficult one that you'll
ever make in your ropewalking career.
Okay.
And that's not saying to rush it
to quickly get to the second one.
No, no.
But to commit.
When you take up the pole...
...make a decision
that you want to go forward.
Yeah.
Take up the pole,
and then embark on a crossing.
Yeah. All I need to do is
get that pole from there to there.
Exactly.
Alright, let's do it.
Okay!
There is a lot more wind
up here today!
(slow breathing)
It's exactly the same trick...
...whether the tightrope...
...is half a metre off the ground...
...or eight metres off the ground.
It's exactly the same thing.
Pole up.
♪ (pulsing percussive music)
Keep breathing. Stay strong.
Lift the chest up.
Stay nice and tall.
Golden thread from the
centre of the head.
No!
Stay up.
(music halts)
I got you.
I got you. Don't you worry.
Stay holding the pole.
Josh, can you grab the pole?
Nice one.
Okay, coming in the last bit.
Thanks, Josh.
Let's do it again.
♪ (tense music resumes)
(deep breathing)
(shaky sigh)
♪ (pulsing percussion)
Strong, stand up tall.
Stand up straight.
Strong and tall, Tom!
Keep breathing.
Slowly, walking forwards.
Keep with your balance.
Keep breathing.
Check those footsteps!
One by one.
Keep breathing with your breath.
I want to hear you breathe!
(strained breathing)
(music intensifies)
Keep going slowly.
Take your time.
Take it one step at a time.
You're all right.
Straighten up!
Okay, easy.
Step by step. Take your time.
Two feet on the wire, please.
Work it. Fight for it. Good.
Keep breathing.
Keep present.
(breathing accelerates)
Keep going, little by little.
Slow it down. Take your time.
You have all the time in the world,
all the space in the world.
This is your space.
Take control of the pole!
Fight for it, Tom!
Easy! Slow down.
Breathing.
Breathing all the way.
Five steps. Slow it down.
And...
Yes!
(grunts)
(applauds) Woo!
Yes!
Thank you, Chris!
Alright, thank you Tom!
Well done, man!
Super cool. Super cool.
It's the same trick!
I can happily just stand on this wire
with hands on here.
But you're right.
I would've touched the ground there.
I'd have considered that a failure.
There's one point, it felt like the pole
was way off down to the side.
I might throw up in a minute.
Have you ever seen anyone
vomit from eight metre high...?
Take your time.
Take your time to breathe.
Take your time to feel grounded,
to arrive into that place of safety.
Great!
Yeah.
Amazing!
Alright!
Beautiful.
On your feet, ropewalker.
Hey! Welcome to my beautiful world.
Thank you so much.
Well done, man.
That was really beautiful.
Oh, that was sketchy at the end.
It doesn't matter how much
you know that's there.
You still feel like you're gonna fall.
It's incredible.
Don't use the F word.
(both laughing)
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]